so listen um
how do we even do this things are
getting really ugly
in the progressive media space and
it pains me to have to do this today but
sam cedar has casually
made a disgusting claim about the david
david pakman show
and fired a shot across the bow about
our recent surge of subscribers
claiming absent any evidence mind you
that somehow bots
that i have presumably used or paid for
are boosting our youtube subscriber
numbers
let me give you a little background last
week by the way this is all a joke just
because i know people will
this is all a joke okay last week the
david pakman show hit
900 000 youtube subscribers this was a
major major deal for us
and we got from 800 000 to 900 000 in
the matter of just a few months
and um it was alleged
that i established sort of a race
against
sam cedar to a million subscribers
that's very much untrue i didn't even
know where sam was from the standpoint
of subscribers
what i established last week was a race
against the clock
not against anybody else i said let's
get to a million by
election day okay now we were not on
track to reach that
as of last week we were projected to
reach a million on january 9th
um thanks to the last 10 days of people
pounding that subscribe button churning
that subscribe button
dremeling the subscribe button you know
all of the battle of
all the stuff uh we were uh updated
to maybe be on track to hit a million by
december 25th
this was apparently brought to sam
cedar's attention
and in the midst of this he has made the
sick vile claim that we are using
bots um check this out
and indeed it turns out we are just a
few thousand subscribers apart now
it is totally plausible that either of
us could get to a million
first and that's great i mean in this
case you know with with trickle-down
taxes a rising tide does not lift all
boats in this case i think a rising tide
does lift all boats
we get cross recommendations on youtube
if more people watch sam i get more
recommendations from his videos if more
people watch
me sam gets more recommendations from my
videos at least presumably
so that's my view but during a call to
sam
yesterday it was disgustingly
suggested by sam that we are using bots
take a look at this very
ugly allegation i appreciate the message
uh ronald reagan
uh let twitter battles die except for
uh for specific people so i appreciate
that
yeah one other one other thing uh pacman
is out there
challenging you to a race to a million
um
you know he's really coming after you
and he's pulling away you guys were
basically tied around
90 908 908 000 uh
youtube subscribers he's already at uh
9 12. and some people on twitter were
saying
well yeah that's because pacman does
more videos but that's like saying
the person who runs the race faster
wins and that makes the race unfair i
mean
i don't know he just seems to be
outworking you i smell bots
i smell bots now this is completely
irresponsible for sam to make this
allegation it's actually sick
um and if i were you i'm talking to the
900 and
however many thousand 918 000 people in
my audience
sam's saying that you don't exist okay
this is
the epitome of depersonalization
sam is saying you you think you just
subscribed to my channel you think
you're a person
you don't exist you're a bot you don't
matter it's like you're not even real
um let's watch a little more because it
actually gets worse
so look here here it is right now put
this video up
look folks ronald reagan has just
informed me
that uh david pakman has taken a lead in
our race
to get to a million subscribers
and i am making a personal appeal to you
right now hit the subscribe button
it's not necessarily where i'm pointing
to i don't know where it is maybe it's
maybe it's down here or over there but
hit the subscribe button
don't let david pakman steal our valor
thank you uh for the reminder he's he's
he's stolen enough as far as i'm
concerned but also okay
but also yes i think that you two need
to to work out some stakes
um and i was thinking that uh the loser
has to use
uh the winner's promo code in their ad
in their ad spots for
like a month for a month so you would do
the cbd
you would do the cbd farm ad but then
say
coupon code d pacman or whatever it is
no our coupon code is left is best i'm
not doing that
i'll do the sun's out guns out challenge
though
i'll do the sun's outgunner where we
wear it yeah
so sam they're raising the idea of a
sun's out gut a
sun's out guns out challenge where we
wear tank tops and expose our biceps i
don't know
about that i don't know how much that
resonates with me um but we can't allow
this to happen right i mean after such a
disgusting shot across the bow was fired
we can't just sit back and let them do
this i hope people are with me here and
then by the way
it gets even worse an hour later in the
show look at these dirty tricks
sam for the sub battle i will make sure
to unsubscribe from pacman to help you
in the race you should tell your subs to
do the same
until you hit 1 million no i don't
you're no roger stone here i'm not i'm
not going to make a call for that
after i just read your call for it so
why would i do it so that's even grosser
sam
indirectly calling for people to
unsubscribe from me without really
calling for it right
i don't have to i would never say that
and why would i because the caller just
did or
the text or it's disgusting guys so
uh this just as a heads up this is all
fake
it's all a joke the only serious part is
let's get to a million help me get to a
million and sam help everybody
you it's not like voting where you can
only vote once you can vote for
everybody
okay if you are anything like me
you probably aren't thrilled with the
idea of going into
a doctor's office right now and
thankfully there is a practical and
affordable way
to take control of your health and get
personalized
care from the comfort of your home it's
a service called
steady md they're one of our sponsors
you take a quiz
you get matched with a licensed primary
care physician
who understands your health needs you
have a one hour video call with your new
doctor
you establish a meaningful relationship
with them and after that
your doctor is available to you anytime
by text phone or video chat this is not
a random doctor on call
each doctor at steady md has a limited
number of patients so they actually have
time
to listen to you you get the personal
attention that you deserve
they can do almost everything an
in-person doctor can do
perform medical evaluations talk to you
about health concerns
send prescriptions to your home or local
pharmacy
and anything they can't do online
they'll quickly set you up with
an in-person provider to do things like
blood tests as an example
you don't need insurance it's only 99
bucks a month with
no other fees or copays there are so
many
practical advantages to using steady md
for primary care
and it's also so much more affordable
go to steadymd.com pacman to take the
free quiz
see which doctor is right for you i took
their quiz they matched me with
a doctor who specializes in my
particular health needs and situation
the doctor they gave me is a really
perfect fit for me and my medical needs
there's no risk no commitment to get
started just click the link right
underneath this video